Hello. This is
Six Minute English
from BBC
Learning English.
I'm Neil.
And I'm Beth.
Names tell us a lot about a person.
Many names have meanings.
Paul, for example,
means humble, and the name
Anna originated from a
Hebrew word meaning graceful.
Our name is an important part
of our identity.
If you hear someone shout your name
in the street,
you automatically turn to look.
But names also reveal cultural
and family connections which give us
a sense of our history
and our place in the world.
In this programme, we'll be meeting
a writer whose name combines
two very different sides
of her identity –
one English and the other Indian.
Sheela Banerjee was born in Hayes,
West London, to parents
from the East Indian state of Bengal.
We'll be hearing about Sheela's research
into her name and family history.
And, as usual,
we'll be learning some
useful new vocabulary as well.
But first, I have
a question for you, Neil.
As every parent knows,
choosing your child's name
isn't easy. Names go in
and out of fashion and a name
that was popular one year,
soon becomes old fashioned.
So, what was the most popular name
for baby girls in the UK last year?
Was it A. Florence, B. Olivia,
or C. Amelia?
I guess it was
Olivia.
OK, Neil. We'll find out the answer
later in the programme.
Sheela Banerjee's name came
out of her parents' journey
from British India to West London
in the 1950s.
Here she tells BBC
Radio 4 programme,
Word of Mouth,
how reflecting on this journey
inspired her new book,
What's in a name? which blends her own
life story with history and politics:
As soon as I started thinking
about it, you know, this name
Sheela, which is, you know, I was a
7-year-old girl living in Hayes called
Sheela - this very typical
English name - you know,
what's that name doing there...
if you start to pull at that,
the threads lead you to the story of
my Bengali parents' migration over here,
to mass migration from the colonies
after the war to this country,
and then Banerjee contains all
these stories about
colonialism and caste.
Her parents wanted their daughter
to feel safe in London
so they gave her
a typical English name,
Sheela. If something is typical,
it shows the usual features of
a particular type of person or thing.
It is a good example of that type.
She may have had
a typical English name,
but with dark skin and hair,
Sheela didn't look
like some people's image
of a typical English girl. Wanting
to find out more about her culture,
Sheela started to pull the threads
behind her family story.
Pulling the threads is an idiom
meaning to investigate deeper
into something, revealing
the hidden connections behind it.
What Sheela discovered was a story
of mass migration – periods in history
when large groups of people move
from one geographical area
to another. Mass migrations
have happened throughout
history in the 1950s and 60s.
Many South Asian families, including
Sheela's, migrated west to cities in the UK.
But this is just one half
of the story.
Sheela's family name, Banerjee,
reflects her roots
in the Bengali culture of East India,
where surnames
tell a lot about a person's
social status or caste.
Here's Sheela explaining
more to BBC
Radio 4 programme,
Word of Mouth.
It is an Indian name,
but actually it's not my real name.
You've got names like Banerjee,
Mukherjee, Chatterjee, which, you know,
nowadays people hear over here,
but Banerjee is an anglicised form
of my original name which
would have been ‘Bandyopadhyay’
and it’s a name that was changed by the
British when they went over there
because they really basically couldn't
be bothered to pronounce it,
or couldn't pronounce it,
and for me it's always
been a very mixed name
because it signifies that we were,
you know, colonial subjects and so
it's a tricky name to
be carrying around.
Sheela's surname is
actually pronounced ‘Bandyopadhyay’
but during colonial times
the name became anglicised –
it was changed to sound more English.
This happened a lot:
the surnames Chattopadhyay
became Chatterjee,
and Mukhopadhyay became Mukherjee,
either because the British rulers
could not pronounce them,
or because they couldn't be bothered –
they didn't make the effort.
Sheela feels her anglicised surname
has always been tricky – difficult to use,
because of the association
with colonialism and oppression.
Ironically, it was London, the
capital of the British Empire, that
in modern times became the destination
for migrants from all over the world.
OK, it's time to reveal the answer
to your question, Beth.
What was the most popular
girls' name in 2022?
I guessed it was Olivia...
Which was...the correct answer!
In 2022, Olivia
remained the most popular girls' name
for the sixth year in a row
and was given to 3,649 baby girls.
OK, let's recap the vocabulary
from this programme,
starting with typical – containing
the most usual features of
a particular type of person or thing.
If you pull the threads of something,
you investigate it more deeply
to find the hidden stories behind it.
Mass migration is the historical
movement of large groups of people
from one place to another.
If something is anglicised, it's changed
to sound or appear English.
If you can't be bothered
to do something,
you don't make the effort to do it.
And finally, if something is tricky,
it is difficult to manage
and requires careful use.
Once again,
our six minutes are up.
Goodbye for now.
Bye!